it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story Boris Johnson is referred
to police over new claims he broke
covered lockdown Rules by hosting
friends at checkers
the former prime minister is already
being investigated by MPS his lawyers
say what he did was lawful
also tonight the fiery Riot on the
streets of Cardiff as police face
questions over an apparent pursuit of
two teenagers who then died
searching for signs of what happened to
Madeleine McCann the police scouring a
Reservoir in Portugal
by Family Ties will no longer count for
foreign students barred from bringing
their families to the UK to try to cut
net migration figures
upgrade to the economy from the IMF but
they warned that inflation could stick
around for longer than expected
and living in public dying in secret the
family of the disgraced TV star Ralph
Harris revealed he's passed away
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
foreign
Boris Johnson was already facing a steep
climb to ascend again to the summit of
politics tonight that looks positively
everestian after it was confirmed he's
been referred to the police over new
claims he broke lockdown rules his
ministerial diary has revealed that
friends went to the prime minister's
country retreat at Checkers during the
pandemic in the next few weeks an MPS
committee is due to rule on a potential
punishment over other breaches in
Downing Street our political
correspondent Joe Pike has this report
the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth it's the issue that's
dogged him and damaged him for more than
a year I'm here to say to you hand on
heart that I did not lie to the house we
knew about lockdown busting parties at
Downing Street but did the rule breaking
extend to Checkers with the Prime
Minister inviting friends to his
official country residence in
buckinghamshire
while Boris Johnson has been touring the
world making speeches and making money
government lawyers have handed evidence
from his own ministerial Diaries to the
police
the assertion by the cabinet office that
there have been further covert rule
breaches is totally untrue lawyers have
examined the events in question and
advised that they were lawful no contact
was made with Mr Johnson before these
incorrect allegations were made both to
the police and to the Privileges
committee this is both bizarre and
unacceptable
and while Boris Johnson's allies want to
move on I'm just hearing this now but my
sense of all of this is that frankly the
prime minister or former prime minister
has been through that we've investigated
that the country's dealt with that I
think the world's moved on quite frankly
and it raises further questions about
um the role of the Civil Service in all
of this opposition parties are angry
right now I think the Prime Minister
Richie sunak needs to make sure that not
a single penny more is spent on Boris
Johnson's defense during his uh lying
inquiry and I think Boris Johnson in
light of everything that's happened
needs to consider whether really he
should be an MP I just believe it's
wrong that the taxpayer is continuing to
fund Boris Johnson's legal defense here
but she soon act should bring that to an
end and Boris Johnson will now have to
explain himself yet again to the
authorities this is just more sleeves
both the met and Thames Valley police
are now investigating if he saw a friend
on a social visit when you shouldn't
have
it will be fixed penalty notices
um if that was um if this that wasn't
um forming within one of the exceptions
and the rules so you know in the region
of
5200 and something pounds
these latest Revelations could delay the
Privileges committee inquiry into
whether Mr Johnson misled Parliament and
yet again it dragged would you soon act
into answering questions about the past
when he's desperate to focus on the
future
and Joe's in Downey Street tonight and
Joe the sense was a potential political
comeback for Boris Johnson had been
receding had it got uh even more remote
now do you think
I think it probably has Anna but the
real problem here I think is really for
a Rishi sunak on his first day at
Downing Street on the steps behind me he
promised Integrity professionalism
accountability every level of government
and yet bad headlines about bad past
alleged Behavior just seemed to not want
to stop you've got Boris Johnson and
partygate omnipresent you've got
recently Dominic Raab and how he treated
civil servants the deems to Harvey's
finances and then in the past few days
Weller Brotherman and this speed
awareness course issue which isn't yet
resolved of course these sort of mini
scandals don't have the prime minister
at their heart although Richie soon Act
of course was fined for one party gate
event but this does tarnish I think
those in number 10 believe the
conservative brand something that of
course wants to burnish the head of the
next general election expected next year
the other issue here which I think is of
concerned some conservative MPS is the
fact that the Civil Service and the
cabin office were the ones to refer all
of this information to both the police
and the Privileges committee it feeds
into a worry a concern in some parts of
the conservative party the back benches
that some civil servants aren't being
entirely fair and balanced with how they
have worked with some conservative
ministers now of course senior civil
sermon central the Prime Minister would
contest that but it doesn't help Rishi
sunak in governing and that is difficult
when he has a lot of challenges on his
plate including immigration later this
week
thank you
police in South Wales have referred
themselves to their Watchdog tonight
after a crash which killed two teenagers
and led to a riot CCTV footage appeared
to show officers pursuing two people on
an electric bike teenagers Kyrie
Sullivan and Harvey Evans died and
fireworks were thrown at police in the
violence which followed Dan Whitehead
reports from the scene
the fires burned through the night in
this residential area of Cardiff
violent clashes erupted between police
and around 150 people
triggered by the deaths of two teenage
boys fifteen-year-old Harvey Evans and
16 year old Kyrie Sullivan both killed
in a crash just meters away with
significant questions over whether
they'd been chased by police
in the light of day the true extent of
the damage was clear
amid the cleanup operation fires still
smoldered people's cars either smashed
or burnt out
at the scene of the crash Harvey's
godmother told Sky News the violence
broke out because of how police dealt
with the victim's families
I just was having none of it they
wouldn't let the men the dads come up
and see their own kids laying on the
floor wouldn't even let them do nothing
it was disgusting how they treated him
yeah it was Harvey like Harvey was a
good he was amazing like a Beverly guy
like just always always happy always on
the go
police say officers were injured during
the violence a number of arrests have
been made and police say there will be
more to be honest very scary
in the night but honestly it was
terrible I've never ever seen like that
situation in my lifetime
police say the level of violence towards
emergency services and damage to
property and vehicles was totally
unacceptable there will be questions now
to answer as to how this situation
escalated so quickly
CCTV footage appears to show two people
on a bike quickly followed by a police
van it was captured just three minutes
before the fatal crash less than half a
mile away this footage is being
recovered as part of the investigation
and will assist us in piecing together
the circumstances leading up to the
Collision
the families are being kept up to date
we can confirm that the following
investigations have been carried out so
far and when the Collision occurred
there were no police vehicles on Snowden
Road
police took no questions but the force
confirmed it has referred itself to the
police watchdog
Community leaders want calm here but
there is tension and a need for answers
as to what led to the deaths of two
young boys
Dan Whited Sky News in Ely Cardiff
well the violence last night spread
across a small area in the west of
Cardiff our data and forensics unit and
correspondent Tom Cheshire have been
looking at what we know of what exactly
happened and when well there's another
one going off here watch out this was
the climax of the violence on stanway
road it had been building for hours this
is the story of how a road Collision
became a ride
Ely is about five miles west of Cardiff
City Center this is the earliest footage
we have filmed on Frank Road and now
part of the investigation 5 59 in the
evening an electric bike and a police
fan apparently following behind
the stretch of road is eight and a half
meters long based on the time taken for
both vehicles to cross the Sky News data
and forensics team calculates their
traveling at around 28 miles an hour
with the van 15 meters behind the bike
officers are called to the scene of the
crash on Snowden Road shortly afterwards
at 6 03 pm
there are two bodies which we've blurred
to the right of the bus police said the
collision had already occurred when
offices arrived and the no vehicles were
involved but remember the bus it will
help us understand the location later
a 20 past eight South Wales police
Cardiff tweet to tell people to avoid
coming to the area
police assembled near the intersection
of Snowden road and stanway road to form
a divide between the instant and people
Gathering further down
this is the scene of the accident the
same bus is here down from there on
stanway road more than a hundred people
gather and start throwing projectiles
night falls and the crowd grows more
violent around 10 to 10 they start a
fire it's put out but it's not long
before another is set during the live
stream residents can be heard blaming
police for the death of the two
teenagers in the most heated moments the
crowd attacks police with fireworks in
turn they charge
the action shifts to high Mead Road
nearby but in the early hours the crowd
disperses the cars still burning Tom
Cheshire Sky News
it is 16 years now since Madeleine
McCann disappeared but in the town near
the reservoir being searched by police
the chief suspect is still remembered
one man told us that Christian b a
convicted German sex attacker had
appeared Bohemian and was there a long
time the reservoir is about 30 miles
from where Madeleine went missing in
prior to luge the focus is an area
around a peninsula on the western side
of the reservoir
search teams on foot and in boats have
been seen working throughout the day
Sky's Europe correspondent Siobhan
Robbins is there
they started early after 16 years
without answers there was no time to
lose officers from Germany Portugal and
the UK searching a reservoir 30 miles
from where Madeleine McCann disappeared
the three-year-old went missing from her
hotel room in 2007.
this convicted German sex offender
Christian B has been named as the prime
suspect in the case
he denies any involvement
but this is a place he allegedly called
his paradise and after receiving a
tip-off German prosecutors ordered a new
search
I can't disclose the background at the
moment why we are searching there and
what we hope to find there that shall
remain a secret for the moment
throughout the day teams scoured the
ground hoping it would reveal any
secrets it may hold
teams waited on the water officers
determined to uncover any evidence that
may be hidden here
when you have a look at this Reservoir
it's absolutely massive and the idea of
being able to search it all in two days
seems like a mammoth task but from
watching the teams here they appear to
be focusing on carefully controlled
areas this search is clearly targeted
Christian B lived in the area when
Madeleine went missing from prior to
luge her disappearance sparked a huge
investigation drawing worldwide
attention in the town near the reservoir
people still remember him Constantino
describes him as a Bohemian who he'd see
wandering around
he was here for a long time
I knew him from sight because I used to
work at prior Deluge at some of the
events
and he was there when it happened
in physio
for more than a decade this tragedy has
left a shadow on the region once again
people here and across Portugal are
hoping for answers
Siobhan Robbins Sky News in Portugal
a man who murdered a seven-year-old girl
was sentenced to a minimum of 29 years
in jail today but for Nikki Allen's
mother it was not enough she has waited
three decades to see David Boyd
convicted and says he should have had
life without parole Skies north of
England correspondent shinki marike has
this report
for more than three decades Sharon
Henderson has fought tirelessly for
justice today her daughter's murderer
was finally sentenced but it wasn't the
sentence she hoped for and I thought
life would have meant life was so poor
I've been let down again by the justice
system that night in 1992 David Boyd
lured Nikki to a derelict building
beating her with a brick and stabbing
her 37 times in the chest
in sentencing Boyd the judge said Nikki
would have felt unimaginable Terror
Nikki must have been petrified
it would not have taken the
seven-year-old long to appreciate that
she was trapped in that cold and dark
building and that you were coming
through the window to get her the
original police investigation was
riddled with mistakes
the investigation was reopened in 2017
with advances in forensics allowing
officers to match Boyd's DNA to traces
found on Nikki's clothing decades after
she was killed in a victim impact
statement read out in court Sharon said
that she fell after the original
investigation that she had to fight for
justice for Nikki and that she was
frustrated that she felt she wasn't
listened to but this time police worked
hard to prove Boyd was responsible for
us as an investigation team we've had to
go through all of that material to look
and scrutinize what was done in 1992 up
until 2013 and then from when we've
started as well so it's been a real
challenge
um from an investigative point of view
and that is why it's taken some time as
well to get to the point where we are
now so many things have changed in the
three decades since Sharon lost Nikki
who she called her bright and Sparky
child who had a beautiful smile but the
pain hurt and anger remained the same
shinki marike Sky News Newcastle Crown
Court
Russia says more than 70 attackers part
of an alleged incursion from Ukraine
have been killed in the Belgard region
Moscow has blamed Ukrainian militants
but videos posted by the groups suggest
they are Russians fighting against
President Putin's forces
a disciplinary panel has decided that
failures by a former metropolitan police
officer to properly investigate two
flashing reports made against Wayne
cousins amounted to gross misconduct the
panel found that former PC Samantha Lee
did not make the correct inquiries over
two incidents reported at a restaurant
in Kent in February of 2021 one of which
happened just days before cousins
murdered Sarah everard
Prince Harry has lost his legal
challenge over being allowed to pay for
police protection when he's in the UK a
judge ruled the committee which included
a representative of the late queen and
the Home Secretary had correctly found
allowing Harry to do so would not be in
the public interest
record-breaking immigration figures are
expected to be announced later this week
and today the government moved to try to
reduce them in the future the families
of most International students will from
January find it much harder to join them
in the UK something which universities
told us could disproportionately impact
women our political correspondent Liz
Bates has more
this is Gustavo he's an international
student at Glasgow University living
with his wife and two daughters but
under new measures designed to lower
immigration his family wouldn't be
entitled to be here with him it's not
just about
stood in and are walking
I also have my duties as a
as a father
so
I would not I I would not come if they
could not come with me
it's part of an effort to bring down the
UK's soaring immigration numbers that
have been causing problems for the Prime
Minister even overshadowing some of the
recent G7 Summit in Japan not helped by
his Home Secretary are you failing on
immigration targets retreat it's been a
tough time for the Home Secretary she's
been causing tensions firstly by piling
pressure on the prime minister to bring
immigration numbers down at the same
time she's been accused of breaking the
ministerial code over a speeding ticket
all this as new immigration figures are
about to come out that show by its own
standards her department is failing
today's announcement should go some way
to reversing the trend as in 2019 269
000 students with study visas brought an
additional 16 000 dependents last year
that number had rocketed to 486
000 student visas and 136
000 dependents
it's been welcomed by many conservative
MPS who say reducing immigration is
important to their voters but there is
concern among universities about which
students this could affect I think it's
clear that if anything that reduces the
ability to bring dependence is almost
certainly going to affect female
students for example we know that
globally women have greater care and
responsibilities so we really think that
the review process that has actually
been announced as part of this package
really needs to look at that what's the
impact on particular communities
back in Glasgow Gustavo is reflecting on
his time in the UK a reminder of the
people behind the policies Liz Bates Sky
News Westminster
the IMF has not been the government's
favorite International forecaster in
recent years repeatedly playing down the
prospects of the UK economy today though
it upgraded its economic predictions and
said the UK won't after all be the
lagard among major industrialized
nations but it wasn't all positive news
as our economics and data editor Ed
Conway explains
but this is the latest health check from
the international monetary fund on the
state of the UK economy and let's just
show you what they were forecasting last
time around this is showing you not just
the UK you can see that over there on
the right hand side the Red Bar there
but also other economies around the G7
The Group of Seven industrialized
economies and you've got the us there
Canada Japan and you can see look
Britain does have the weakest growth in
2023 and when I say great that's gross
domestic product growth the rates at
which our national income is growing
each year so that was last time around
that was only a few months ago have a
look at these latest forecasts look at
the Red Bar there look it goes up it
goes up from minus 4.3 to 0.4 still
pretty weak by the standards of recent
years but nonetheless not the weakest in
the G7 anymore and a lot of people are
asking if the IMF can make big mistakes
like this in their forecasts how much
should we trust their numbers anymore
this is what I put to the managing
director how important is it how big of
a deal is it if the IMF does keep
getting things wrong does that damage
your rep mutation do you think I
actually think that
our staff my colleagues deserve credit
for being agile in how we look at
changing conditions and being fast
to adjust projections so we can give as
clear a picture as we can at the time
that you would agree is the focus we
have seen in many decades one other
thing the fund is talking about is the
idea that inflation so the rate at which
prices are rising each year could be
stickier than people had expected what's
that mean well this line is showing you
inflation the rate at which we are
seeing that cost of living increasing
you can see how it's gone up into double
digit levels uh recently here's what the
bank of England recently thought that
was going to happen to inflation it was
going to come down quickly they thought
in November they thought it would come
down really quickly when they did
updated those forecasts in February they
thought it would come down even more
quickly so look at that blue line now
the latest forecast and the IMF
basically endorses this look that blue
line goes even further out into the
future so higher inflation for longer
and they say that also means that
interest rates potentially could be
higher for longer all of these things
that are squeezing people's living
standards could go on for longer than
anyone would like
it can we there now for months the
questions has been will he or won't he
but tomorrow the waiting will end for
the one man who it seems might stand
half a chance of stopping Donald Trump
having another run at the White House
Rhonda santis aiming to be the
Republican nominee at the next U.S
election is expecting to announce his
presidential bid in an event with Elon
Musk or Skies U.S correspondent Mark
Stone joins us now from Palm Beach
County in Florida so does that answer
the where Mark Florida at least but what
about the when and how this announcement
will be made
well look we don't know it'll be Florida
to be honest Dana all we do know is
there will be an in cyberspace it will
be on Twitter uh in a an audio
conversation uh with the owner of
Twitter that Elon Musk it's certainly
not a a conventional presidential uh run
announcement but then he is not a
conventional politician uh rather like
the man he would like to beat uh Donald
Trump in terms of beating to the to be
the Republican uh nomination uh Ronda
santis is not your average politician
but he is very very popular indeed down
here in Florida where he is serving his
second term as Governor he won that
second term last year with a landslide
uh majority uh he is a man who some say
um is Trump without the chaos a man who
who has parroted many trumpian policies
but he but people think that he could
deliver those in a way that Trump
because of his chaos was unable to which
either makes him a very exciting
candidate or a very frightening a
candidate the um the polit the
announcement will be as I say uh on um
uh Twitter tomorrow night local time 6
p.m we also expect that there will be a
campaign video as well that will be
released
um and I can tell you that having
traveled down the east coast of Florida
through the course of today yes many
people are very very excited about this
man that that fights wokism that says
that uh wokism comes to die in Florida
one of his catchphrases they're excited
by him but this is always has been a
swing state there are plenty here who
are pretty concerned about a president
DeSantis
keep an eye on that uh thank you very
much I need Mark Stone there live in
Florida
Ralph Harris lived his final years in
solitude and disgrace one of the best
known names from British television for
four decades but also a convicted
pedophile his family revealed today he's
died at the age of 93. his death
certificate suggests he passed away
nearly two weeks ago Katie Spencer
reports
[Applause]
Club
he was for many decades a much-loved
face on British television
time as an Entertainer Rolf Harris built
his hugely successful career on his
appeal to Children an appeal he
leveraged hiding the fact he was a
sexual predator
Harris was welcomed everywhere you're
okay with the smell of turpentine I hope
well we'll tell weren't we soon
you feel it all over your skin that's
good and it's sort of feeling you want
to give somebody a big hug like that
trusted even to warn kids about
pedophiles he'd been abusing children
for years when he made this educational
video and it's that sort of touching I
want to talk about today because it
helps you to understand
the sort of touching that doesn't make
you feel too good my heart goes out to
those survivors today who are carrying a
burden of pain that's got nothing to do
with anything they did and everything to
do with a predator who used his
celebrity his position of influence to
engage with them and and ultimately
abuse them until his arrest in 2013 he
enjoyed a stellar career making his
first appearance here at what used to be
BBC television Center and after decades
on our screens his Fall From Grace would
be spectacular his MBA Obe CBE would all
be taken away from him after he was
convicted for sexually assaulting two
young girls
Harris was 84 by the time his crimes
caught up with him his youngest victim
was seven his wife Alwyn stood by him
throughout so too his daughter Bindi
even though he was convicted for
grooming her childhood friend repeatedly
indecently assaulting her from the age
of 13. people will remember him as an
Entertainer remember to a certain time
for a period of time is unique that he
actually lived in the hearts of the
nation and also was pretty good at
Reinventing himself you know he took to
the main stage at Glastonbury became one
of those you know guilty pleasures for
for for the for the rock and roll world
but he will be remembered unfortunately
for his crimes
released from prison after three years
Harris never publicly admitted his
crimes dismissing his victims as Seekers
of Fame and money struggling with how
he'd gone from TV personality to Pariah
Katie Spencer Sky News
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including Rolf Harris's death featuring
on the front of the Metro its headline
vile rolf's secret funeral as you can
see well tonight we'll be joined by the
observer's chief leader writer Sonia
soda and the home Affairs editor of the
times Matt datham
[Music]
foreign
thank you